they say when a youtuber is dying the  videos flash before their eyes like the  psychological horror of live alone or  the haunting isolation of micro hora the  end  remember that time I interviewed marina  gory Venus arena what's happening marina  [Music]  everybody loved all Dane take kruky pasa  hologram Rick shocking and true fear  last time I'm here I want to talk about  more trailers and prizes like watching  right you'll notice that it's I don't  need to reflect one I want to do more 15  second horrors more dead stream  I'm not satisfied with stopping now so  many ideas I must find a way to create  more assuming people survive  [Music]  [Music]